So with that I'd just like to close and
say, one,
we talked about Epsilon photography.
Sequence of images allowed
us to now capture more
additional representation that will
allow us to generate newer images.
We basically said, let's look
at coded photography, that is,
within the same image captured, let's
put some sort of additional information
in there that could be done by
coded aperture or coded shutter and
that allow us to create, for example,
two different types of images.
We looked at coded aperture in detail.
We looked at flutter-shutter,
which was called a shutter.
And basically all of
them are examples of
how we can actually
do coded photography.
Again, Epsilon photography,
coded photography,
just kinds of similar things
in different ways, but
all aimed at generating novel
images on the camera by controlling
how the camera captures light from a
scene and in essence are major parts of
what we think computational photography
should be looking more and more at.
You'll be learning more
about these things and
other ways throughout the class with
some additional papers that I'm going to
be pointing out to you.
To finish, here is the paper that
actually gets into the whole concept of
Epsilon to coded photography,
then the paper that I talked about,
coded apertures.
This is the paper about
fluttered shutter cameras.
Just if you're interested in the Lucy
Richardson deconvolution methods there's
a Wikipedia entry on
it that's pretty good.
And again, for those of you interested
in learning more about the discrete
fourier transform and the sync functions
for different types of signals.
There's an online book that has
a lot of in, information on it.
But otherwise find your favorite
textbook on digital processing or
image processing,
they'll tell you how to do these things.
Just again, I've also linked
the websites of the different
projects that I've talked
about in this class.
I encourage you to look at them,
there's a whole lot of
additional detail available